I'll play a complete random challenge
playing WOM Somme or wham Sam always
confused how to pronounce a z' could
mean WOM Sam or wham song let's play
Kings gambit
just for Fatah gone and also recently I
finally learned what a what the double
musio is it's g5 Bishop c4
I think it's g4 castling takes takes at
some point I know II five and then we
take on f7 I have to get to move or go
down Bishop c5 I don't think is a great
move
just cuz it allows d4 with tempo and
life is very good here ya know double
musio no single musio it's just a dream
development how important is it to start
playing chess at a young age
probably not as important as like
learning to read and write and talk but
it's up there you if you start young
you'll definitely have an advantage then
if you start it like in your mid-30s
because when your brain is still
developing you'll and just absorb things
quicker connect Greek gift here Bishop
takes h7 Knight g5 Queen h5 maybe
resigns a Greek gift in the King's
gambits before move 10 it doesn't happen
too often
oh yeah done Feingold said John
Bartholomew is better than me III was
listening to the stream actually I was I
was making food and I had been Feingold
on from a distance I I heard him start
talking about like who's the best I am
now I actually I agreed with most things
that he said I'm John's pretty strong
and then there was this whole debate who
would win in an arm wrestling well
thanks for that doctor DSM yeah we'll
see we both have some tough matches to
come but that would be definitely an
interesting finale play this move
normally when you greet gift you should
you should calculate these lines ahead
of time it's just kind of winging it
here of Queen d3 Queen d3 pretty much
forces at five and then there's on
Poisson or there's queen g3 it's a bit
tricky because the knight on d5 it's a
nice piece for black it's always a
concern about a knight takes Bishop this
looks most promising Queen d3 queen g3
because when I'm threatening to win the
Queen also probably threatening some and
on the 96 Queen takes g7 the other
candidate moves h4 but that just loses a
piece so let's start with this
yeah and all I'll be honest I didn't
really have much of a plan for the
stream so for the time being I'm taking
challenges you can challenge me to
anything any variants if it's too long I
might aborts but um if you have
questions feel free to answer questions
a dead man asking chest network just
network question mark not sure if that's
a question or a statement
unfortunately chest network is not an IM
if shots network wasn't ion then maybe
he'd be part of the speech Chess
Championship for Iams
I think I'm calculating takes night h7
King moves wait a minute I'm also
looking at Queen h3 and I takes that for
Queen h7 King takes here so that
involves I've already sacked one minor
piece that involves sacking two more
minor pieces and then the idea is each
for King g4 Queen takes g7 it's not
meeting though because King h5 g5 is
off-limits because the Queen on d8
there's also ricochet which is slightly
annoying but rotating
okay chain maybe Queen g3 I'll probably
just Queen g3 immediately
at the very least there is some
practical compensation with the pressure
against the king the King Stach too
because all these squares are controlled
by by white things that's very typical
where when the Greek gift happens three
who are D with a heart symbol thanks for
subbing for four months welcome back
something with problem appreciate that
hey and drop drop sad Dominic is
watching from Budapest
I've never been to do the pass always
wanted to go feel like any opening I
play I should at least visit the city
that it's named after what openings
should be avoided and against high rated
players versus a lower level so I'm
imagining you're you're the lower level
player and you're asking which openings
to avoid if you're playing a higher
level player so basically you're just
asking about like which openings are
dubious
yeah Stafford gambit is dubious but it's
also fun I've also played it against
like grandmasters including Nakamura and
it doesn't lose right away
okay Knight here wins the Queen I'm
looking for mate though this one's a
knight let's just win a queen
I didn't see that move but okay take the
queen h3 coming I win the night's king
is still very exposed yeah so that wants
to do this all allow it because yeah
between the Queen the bishop and the
rook there should definitely be some
kind of mates like these these pieces
are not not really helping defend but
yeah um I think tough position even
after Bishop c5 what does Box supposed
to do and move doesn't move three I
think a common move here is actually d5
you give up a pawn to accelerate
development and then it's just kind of
equal material like d5 takes Knight f6
and you can try and win the back yeah
this were with atomic chess Bishop takes
h7 with a1 on the spot I've never been
to Sicily yeah that's another another
chess inspired thing I've been to the
town of I'm probably gonna butcher the
pronunciation chef ending and Sheva
ningún it's a Dutch town very well known
Sicilian variation very nice town it's
on the beach whoa it's Sam axe
Sam axe mm with a rain thanks so much
Charlotte Suzanne it's actually don't
know who that is but I assume it's the
chest reamer
really appreciate it if you're just
joining you just missed a nice kind of
Greek gift emerging from the Kings
gambit yeah from the box side I like to
play d5 and make things crazy I think
even after ye five I would imagine this
should be stockfish approved Bishop
takes h7 sometimes you have to wait a
few seconds until the computer actually
understands tell you if the Kings gambit
bits so let me I'm actually curious I
just want to review what this double
musio is because I know it's g5 Bishop
c4 g4 so it's basically all the most
common moves is it here Queen f6
oh yeah Queen f6 key v Queen takes d5
and then Bishop takes f7 and lights
basically gambits everything like gamma
did the knight the bishop all the pawns
gambits another pawn if black wants it
and oh yeah that Bishop e3 having yet
another pawn okay that's pretty simple
to remember I guess I just forgot Queen
f6 wasn't me move from black but it does
require cooperation for the opponent to
go into that
and he prepped for Feingold I don't know
Feingold was talking earlier about
armwrestling so I have to just start
lifting and throw let's uh let's play
another game I guess
well all except a random challenge
playing pennants
played once before I'll play you for
been fine will beat me once you know I
know over the board tournament so needs
to get revenge okay just for tog II if
I'm holding off on geoguessr I might as
well play the Kings gambit again
diamond-covered welcome back how's it
going yeah I appreciate all the people
who were like offering supports
yesterday's match another Bishop c5 yeah
my first opponent played Bishop c5 and
[Music]
suffered the consequences we're gonna
get the same exact opening as a first
game this is just deja vu this is
complete deja vu I even analyzed it like
afterwards with engine anyone who's here
at the beginning of the stream I had
this exact same position just like maybe
20 minutes ago yeah Knight g5 should
still actually Knight g5 there's a
knight takes f4 oh that's tricky I
wonder if my opponent like prepped for
me now both bishops are hanging there's
no way this is good for black guy I
remember though the computer evaluation
was it was like Plus at least one plus
one point Florida I don't remember if it
was suggesting this or this so
innovative Panda how do you prepare for
a Lina there's different elements to
preparation
not all of it is just specific to one
opponent a lot of it is getting in the
right mind frame sharpening tactics
Otaki might never play me again
oh dear this move calculating Bishop g5
s6 9h for it takes and then Queen h5
with dirty dirty meeting ideas it's
actually kind of nice yeah let's do that
so the line f6 Knight h4 pawn takes
Bishop Queen here threatening Bishop g6
Queen h7 mate and after should we go
into this queen h5 Knight f4 it looks
like a move to attack the Queen but then
there's 96 mates so it's basically two
different mating ideas after Queen h5
hard to stop both yeah talk you saying
if I never play you again I can always
say I did win my last game against Erica
Rosen can put that on on a mug or
something and make that a t-shirt and
that also means you indirectly be
Carlsen ranks there's actually a cool
website you see if I can find the link
you're supposed to read it I don't know
if it's still existing
it was called something like Carlson
number and you just type in your you
have to be a feed a player but you type
in like your feed a ID and then it'll
say how many like games you you are from
indirectly meeting Carlson oh madness
number aha
yeah ok yeah this website so I can type
in rosin and yeah I've actually so I
beat this person who beat this person
who will be Carlson of course it doesn't
include online games so you could even
type in I don't know any like a
low-rated feed a player it's interesting
to see like what what the largest number
is okay yeah those two the the
programmers who I guess say they just
use like fides data or something ok
there should be forced me here
that's nice calculation exercise maybe
first it's a question because I can play
a bit of g6 first or Knight g6 first or
even just takes but kind of drawn to
Knight g6 cuz rook has to take takes
King g8 here here here here he needs six
than queen of sevens mate huh it was
easier than I was expecting I thought
the king was gonna escape somehow I
guess not
oh it doesn't work for Kirk for a takis
name maybe it doesn't work if your name
is is too similar to Carlson alright
let's check yeah so just to show I
wonder like wonder if this has been a
common trap so will be just out of the
base yeah there's only been a handful of
games my games aren't showing up huh
maybe it doesn't update immediately but
yeah Bishop takes h7 and so stockfish of
stuff which does say King h8 is the best
mode that's suggesting it was suggesting
bishops he won the Bishop g5 most
powerful f6 9 h4 oh really well I'm
losing here oh I forgot there's there's
King Jake's h7 I'll block had a chance
wow I was so excited for Queen h5 I just
assumed that everything works but King
takes h7 and I guess black survives like
g6 maybe there's some hidden draw or
maybe not